il n'y a pas de quoi s'en voit cesnek
monsieur des c'est vrai si tu t'es
convoqué partiront là alors là il a
raison tma je sais pas ce qu'on vous a
dit mais quoi qu'on me reproche je ne
l'ait pas fait tu n'as rien fait peur si
non c'est exact comme tu le sais tu es
considéré comme l'unique fils de
poséidon et son seul héritier
ouais et alors eh bien il semble que
finalement nous ayons été induit en
erreur
attendez ça veut dire que percy a un
frère ou une soeur au nom du styx à
notre sang mêlé de poséidon pas tout à
fait techniquement tyson n'est pas un
sommet les îles sang-mêlé sont à moitié
humain comme tulle et toi même je
comprends pas si ce gars n'est pas à
moitié humain il est à moitié quoi la
moitié naf les fils de l'infâme et quand
on croise un dieu et une info en obtient
c'est un crozes hermitage corp a tout
faux elle salue frangin